CBC News The National: Streets flooded, neighborhoods
submerged.
NBC News: You couldn’t see anything but
water, nothing but water.
CBS Mornings: This report by the world’s
leading climate scientists is released just
once every 8 years, and it’s pretty grim.
ABC News: What’s new in this report are
multiple adaptation strategies that can be
successful if the global temperature rise
is limited to 1.5 degrees celsius.
SIERRA: Adaptation is one of those words that
comes up in a lot of different contexts.
And it makes sense right, since the beginning
of time, all living things have been changing,
pivoting and adjusting in order to survive.
SIERRA: When it comes to climate change, conversations
about survival have tended to focus on mitigation
- how the world can reduce and eventually
end its use of fossil fuels.
SIERRA: But adaptation is the other half of
the equation.
It means preparing our homes, our communities,
our infrastructure, and industries, to endure
the effects of climate change.
SIERRA: This month, a blockbuster report published
by the IPCC confirmed the extent to which
devastating climate effects are now unavoidable.
SIERRA: These challenges include more intense
forest fires, heat waves, hurricanes, landslides,
and famine.
Each of these dangers presents an enormous
adaptation challenge.
SIERRA: One of the problems at the top of
the list was sea level rise.
And that’s the part of adaptation that we’re
going to be talking about today - how countries
can adapt in order to save the coastal cities
and the millions of people who live in the
ocean’s path.
SIERRA: I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is
Why It Matters.
Today, adapting to rising tides.
SIERRA: So where are we on the sea level rise
timeline?
JACOB: Well, it began today.
It began yesterday.
It only gets worse tomorrow and the day after
tomorrow.
SIERRA: This is Klaus Jacob, he is a geophysicist,
a disaster and climate expert, and a professor
at Columbia University.
JACOB: The problem is that sea level rise
is actually accelerating.
It gets ever faster and faster in its rise.
And so if we don't foresee that we will not
be able to keep up and so the earlier we start,
the better we're off in the future.
WCVB Channel 5 Boston: This morning, forecasting
our future.
There is a new report painting a dire picture
when it comes to rising sea levels.
Researchers are calling this new data a global
wake up call.
CBS New York: The flood frequencies are going
to increase and they are going to become problematic.
CNN: Coastal cities could flood even on sunny
days.
SIERRA: 40 percent of the world’s population
lives within 100 kilometers of the coast.
SIERRA: One of those people is, me.
I grew up in Manhattan Beach, Brooklyn, it’s
a small community nestled between the ocean
and a bay.
Sandy flooded my community and many other
parts of New York City.
The water reached heights of up to 14 feet,
and it destroyed a large portion of my childhood
home.
When I go back I still see collapsed houses,
and it’s a decade later.
SIERRA: Hurricane Sandy was just one storm,
but it caused an estimated $70 billion dollars
in damages.
The cost of extreme weather and rising sea
levels is predicted to reach around $1 trillion
dollars by 2100, that’s in the US alone.
JACOB: At low sea level, you need a very strong
storm to reach a certain height.
But as sea level rises, you need ever smaller
storms to reach the same point.
But smaller storms are more frequent.
That means the same place floods ever more
frequently.
Sandy, the last major hurricane that hit New
York City in 2012.
That was roughly a storm with a probability
of 1 in 700.
But now the frequency will increase by a factor
anywhere from 50 to 100 more often, the same
place gets flooded.
That's by the end of the century around there.
So it's absolutely amazing how much a seemingly
modest sea level rise can amplify the flood
frequency and therefore the risks that we
incur in time.
Sea level rise is not like a bathtub rising
everywhere the same.
It rises differently in different parts of
the world, it's not only the global sea level,
it's also the local sea level component that
often has a subsidence.
SIERRA: Subsidence basically means that the
land is also sinking.
Especially in regions with rivers or waterways.
JACOB: For instance, in Deltas, like in the
Mississippi River Delta, New Orleans or in
the Amazon delta or in the Nile or any other
major river, Rhine delta in the Netherlands.
Even if there were no global sea level rise
from global warming, locally, you still would
have an apparent sea level rise, which is
really the land sinking.
But now you have both phenomena together and
that is really causing severe problems.
SIERRA: Modeling is tough because sea level
rise depends on how much we mitigate.
Today, global sea levels are predicted to
rise at least 1-3 ft by 2100.
That’s a global average, so in some places
it could be lower or dramatically higher.
For example, let’s go back to the big apple.
SIERRA: According to the NYC Panel on Climate
Change, the city could experience sea level
rise of 6 ft by 2100.
That means that without drastic changes, large
parts of the country’s most populous city
could become uninhabitable.
SIERRA: And this will be happening all over
the world.
By the end of the century, sea level rise
could endanger or displace ​​410 million
people from their homes.
WAGNER: Frankly, sea level rise is an interesting
case, largely because it happens relentlessly
and at an increasing rate.
SIERRA: This is Gernot Wagner.
Climate economist and professor at Columbia
Business School, on leave from NYU.
WAGNER: On the other hand, the pace itself
is relatively low.
So no, we don't have to move New York City
next decade because of sea level rise.
What happens is that sea level rise makes
flooding events much, much more intense.
Storm surges, much, much more intense.
So even something as steady and relentless
as sea level rise has the most costly impact
in terms of the extremes.
As soon as we stop putting CO2 into the atmosphere,
as soon as we are at net zero emissions globally,
temperatures will stop increasing.
Well, if we were to achieve that temperatures
will stop increasing, sea levels will rise
for decades, for centuries after and that
alone tells us how difficult a problem climate
change actually is.
It is the most long term, most global, most
uncertain public policy problem out there,
at least in the combination of those factors.
JACOB: So adaptation can occur in fundamentally
different ways.
There are essentially three.
The first we can call protection, keep the
water out.
The next can be accommodation, let the water
in and live with it.
The third one, namely, is managed retreat
or strategic relocation.
SIERRA: There are a few buckets when it comes
to addressing sea level rise.
We can think of bucket one as seawalls and
barriers, which tend to be what you hear about
most when it comes to adaptation.
Even in my parents’ neighborhood, sea walls
have been the focus of many a very spirited
community board meeting.
JACOB: You can build seawalls on the shoreline
and levees and dikes but there are larger
systems and they have successfully, in the
past, been applied in the Netherlands for
instance, where they built entire barrier
systems.
And they are largely open and only when a
storm comes, will they be closed.
SIERRA: The queen of all barriers is in the
Netherlands and it’s called Maeslantkering,
it is almost as long as the height of the
Eiffel Tower, and it weighs 4 times as much.
There are all sorts of these barriers of different
types and sizes around the world.
JACOB: And that has served in the past, the
Netherlands and some other places very well.
But whenever you have a river coming out,
then these barrier systems have a problem.
Why?
Because they have to be ever more frequently
closed because even smaller storms eventually
lead to the same flood level that you want
to keep out.
But now we have a river coming out that wants
to get through the barriers out into the ocean.
If the barriers are permanently closed, you
get it flooded from behind the barriers.
That means it's not a sustainable adaptation
solution.
SIERRA: Going back to New York, the city is
spending $1.45 billion dollars on something
called the East Coast Resiliency Project,
a multipart barrier system that is set to
wrap by 2026.
In many cases these projects could provide
immediate protection, but some believe their
capacity will be limited in decades to come,
if sea levels continue rising.
And in other places, seawalls might not be
of much use even in the short term.
SIERRA: All of this is a storm surge and it
keeps pouring into parts of downtown Miami.
KLAUS: The geology of Florida is such that
it's made of very permeable limestone.
And water can easily flow through that rock.
So if you build a seawall on top, the ocean
doesn't care, it just flows underneath that
seawall through the limestone behind the seawall.
And so Florida right now is buying tens of
hundreds of millions of pumping systems and
building some seawalls, which is a waste of
time and money.
They should think about how either to build
floatable cities, if they are serious and
trying to stay there, which is not easy, because
there are hurricanes coming in, they can drive
them up or Floridians should think how soon
they want to sell their property and move
up to Appalachia.
SIERRA: As mentioned, on top of barriers,
there are other options, like nature based
solutions, where we’d build out natural
landscapes for protection, one place doing
this already is the Netherlands.
OVINK: So climate adaptation is not only about
building a bigger wall against the flood,
it is really about greening our infrastructure.
SIERRA: This is Henk Ovink, he's a water ambassador,
more specifically a special envoy for international
water affairs for the Kingdom of the Netherlands.
Before this, he worked for President Obama's
Hurricane Sandy Rebuilding Task Force.
We’ve been bringing up the Netherlands a
lot so far and this is why…
OVINK: The Netherlands is a country that is
pretty vulnerable when it comes to flooding.
A third of the country is below sea level,
60% is flood prone.
The way we protect ourselves was not built
overnight.
It's not that all of a sudden we thought,
"Oh, help.
We are not flood prone, what are we going
to do?"
No.
In the ages coming from the 12th century and
even before, we started to develop measures
in our rivers, on our coastlines that helped
us protect to the challenges that occurred
then.
And every time that measure was the baseline
for a next measure and a next measure.
That type of redundancy in our environments,
in our cities, for that matter, coastlines
help.
So for instance, in the Netherlands along
our coast, our sea is battering our coastline.
Because of that, we always have to replenish
our beaches.
But instead of that now, we build an island
in front of the coast, an artificial island
with sand.
Now, because of the current of the ocean,
the sand is distributed along the coast and
therefore we don't have to replenish it ourselves.
But that doesn't work, let's say in Miami
where the coastline definitely is not sandy.
You can't come up with such an approach like
we did in the Netherlands, so you have to
think about totally different.
And then if you go to Bangladesh where the
mangroves are protecting the impact of the
floods and the hurricane cyclones that they
have there, those mangroves are battered by
industrialization and pollution.
But restoring those mangroves in Bangladesh
or Indonesia helps those coastlines become
more resilient.
So there are many ways across the world that
resiliency and adaptation builds redundancy,
capacity, for coastlines and communities but
they are different everywhere.
SIERRA: And these concepts are also really
important for how we rebuild after a disaster.
OVINK: If you build back, you build back according
to new standards not to old.
There's infrastructure investments being it
a house, a factory or a road, there are building
codes.
So there are flood maps, there is data and
analytics.
So I think from government, private sector,
and community, there's a lot you can do.
If the flood maps are not up to date, well,
you just have the wrong flood maps.
If the data on the building codes is not future
proof, then the codes have to be made future.
So there's many of those generic things that
you have to do.
SIERRA: Ok, so that was bucket one - keeping
the water out.
But at a certain point, those efforts might
not be sustainable.
And that brings us to bucket two of sea level
adaptation - letting the water in.
OVINK: I remember in the Netherlands, in our
large infrastructure program called Room for
the River where based on flood events in the
90s we said, "We have to give the rivers more
room again."
So, we started not with the solutions, we
started with the assessment that we needed
to make sure that our rivering system was
ready for that future.
Also in the Netherlands people don't like
the government telling them to move away,
we're no different than any other place around
the world.
So we went into the communities and worked
with the farmers and the citizens.
And what happened, there was one place that
we needed for flood retention.
The farmers that lived there had to move.
But we also provided the farmers with funding
to do research and come up with their own
plan.
So we provided them with experts and expertise
and capacity, and they came up with an alternative
plan.
And what was interesting, that alternative
plan worked better than just moving them away.
Because they said, "We want to stay, this
is our farm and that of our fathers and grandfathers.
And it has to be for our daughters and sons
and grandchildren."
So instead of moving them away, we took the
farms apart and we built terps, a terp is
like higher ground.
Built new farms on top of them that were also
sustainably green.
And now the farmers live in an environment
that can flood, that they can be isolated
for a couple of days and then the water flows
again.
They take that risk.
But this is where they live.
SIERRA: The idea is simple.
Rather than fighting the water, you build
urban or rural infrastructure so that the
water can flood in a controlled or planned
way.
OVINK: I look at Harvey in Houston.
The combination of a hurricane and a massive
rain event flooded the city.
The rivering system had not enough capacity
to deal with both the surge that came in with
the hurricane and the rain event.
And the way the rivering system and the bayou
system was actually interrupted by infrastructure
and housing ensured that the disaster became
also a disaster for the people that lived
in Houston.
And with that, you can rethink, you can really
assess that situation, say, "Okay, what did
we do wrong?
And how can we undo that?"
By, again, creating more room for water, restoring
that bayou system that actually helped create
redundancy in the water system.
Don't build along the river in a way where
you're more vulnerable, but create more room
for the river.
Making sure it can meander again, grow and
shrink.
And with that also create a healthier environment.
Those are things we can do all over the world
to be able to prepare for the risks, and at
the same time, create added value.
SIERRA: There are other fascinating ideas
on how to live with the water too …
JACOB: You can build floating cities.
And the Dutch have already started to do that.
And there are of course floating cities that
have been around for many, many centuries,
go to Asia.
In many harbors, you have essentially boats
where people live on and trade and do their
business from.
SIERRA: There is a whole new industry known
as aqua-tecture, do you get it?
Like architecture.
Anyway the idea is this, when a flood comes,
amphibious homes can float up with the water,
but they’re anchored in such a way that
they come back down when the water recedes.
JACOB: So that is a solution that in someplace,
will work better.
I don't think it works very well for New York
City and Florida, and many other coastal areas
in the Atlantic and in the Gulf because we
have these incredible wind storms with huge
storm tides that come in.
And so to keep floating communities afloat
and not make them drift away and bump into
each other, that would be quite an engineering
feat and I haven't seen anybody trying that
in these areas.
SIERRA: Prevention and accommodation methods
can work together in different ways to meet
rising sea levels, but some feel that even
this doesn’t go far enough.
That brings us to bucket 3, strategic relocation
or managed retreat.
It’s a matter of intense debate within the
adaptation community.
HILL: One of the ways that humans have always
adapted is that people will move.
SIERRA: This is Alice Hill, she’s a senior
fellow for energy and the environment at CFR.
She served at the National Security Council
under President Obama, where she advised on
catastrophic risks like climate change.
HILL: Because if the land disappears from
underneath their feet or a wildfire occurs
and they lose their home.
Or if heat extremes or flooding wipes out
their crops or their livelihoods, those that
can, will in many instances seek to find a
better life in another location.
And we are seeing this dramatically across
the globe.
We're already seeing higher numbers of people
on the move.
Now, they are many reasons that they're displaced
as some referred to climate change as a threat
multiplier or a crisis multiplier.
Climate change adds an additional pressure
on people that can be the culminating event
or just an added pressure that forces them
to the decision to move on.
So we are seeing an estimated 50 million people
a year moving globally as a result of climate-worsened
events.
And as we go forward, their anticipation is
that this type of migration will increase
in fact, to the point where our national intelligence
agencies have warned this may be one of the
largest consequences going forward.
And of course, when people are on the move
that creates security risks.
For the people on the move, it creates tensions
among communities as there's conflicts over
already restricted or reduced resources.
You can think of many people moving into a
community where there's not enough freshwater,
not enough food.
And then there's a whole new set of needs
expressed by the people who are moving into
the community.
And we see that we are at risk of very chaotic
migration if we don't think about planning
ahead.
One country that is facing an existential
threat from climate change that's the country
of Bangladesh, which is about the size of
Iowa.
The state of Iowa.
It has 200 million people in it.
It's crisscrossed by rivers and then it has
a lot of coastline.
So it's facing huge flooding risks for its
population.
JACOB: There are some tens of millions of
peoples that will be displaced in Bangladesh
alone.
Where do they go?
Well, not sure India or Malaysia wants to
have them suddenly coming into their country.
And we are complaining about a few immigrants
from Central and South America coming into
the US, well wait until sea level rise makes
millions of people, tens of millions of people
knocking at our doors.
SIERRA: It also means abandoning your home?
JACOB: Your home, your heritage, your culture,
many things.
And that is the big, big puzzle.
Physically and financially, if we show the
political will, it's doable.
But the social cultural aspect is the hardest
nut to crack.
SIERRA: It can be hard to imagine this scale
of change.
Potentially abandoning cities that define
our culture.
Imagine massive crowds fleeing places like
New Orleans, Mumbai, Hong Kong, Manila, Tokyo
and Shanghai.
This could be the future we face.
SIERRA: Moving entire cities would be totally
unprecedented.
That’s why proponents of strategic relocation
think that we have to move quickly to put
plans, and funding, in place, to figure out
how to do it in the best way possible.
SIERRA: And that brings up an important part
of the adaptation picture.
Whatever the policy, it’s going to cost
a lot of money.
HILL: One 2019 estimate found that real estate
worth 1.4 trillion is already located within
just 700 feet of the US coast.
And that sea level rise alone is projected
to affect somewhere between four and 13 million
Americans.
Retreat from these coastlines would cost a
great deal of money.
If just 1/10th of these people or buildings
retreated, it would cost an estimated $140
billion.
So we know that ahead we are going to face
some very costly choices about what to do
to help communities that live in these areas,
already under threat as they make choices
about how to live with a changing coastline.
SIERRA: So what types of costs is climate
change overall already causing here in the
US?
HILL: The United States last year suffered
20 separate billion-dollar climate and weather
disasters with total losses reaching $145
billion.
So we are already paying a big price in terms
of climate change.
And last year it wasn't just the United States
that was hit.
Across the globe, the world incurred $329
billion in total economic losses from climate
and weather catastrophes, according to some
insurers.
And of course, without insurance and many
of these threats are not insured, the recovery
costs fall on those who are harmed or on their
governments or philanthropies that are able
and willing to help them.
Swiss Re, which is one of the world's largest
reinsurers.
Swiss Re projected last year that if we continue
on our current course of heating, world gross
domestic product would drop by 18% by 2050.
So we are not yet internalizing the costs
that come from climate impacts and their cascading
casualties as a result of a flood that then
wipes out a community.
Kids aren't going to school.
There's more illness in the community.
The tax base shrinks.
All those things that happen, we could be
at risk for greater economic loss going forward
and really on a very wide scale across the
globe.
WAGNER: We are frankly very much still in
the mode of having the federal government
come in and bail us out over and over and
over again which of course right from perspective
of the homeowner, this is our social construct.
This is our understanding.
Catastrophe happens.
President declares Federal Emergency, FEMA
comes in and helps.
And that's a good thing.
That's not necessarily stop this, but of course
it also comes with unintended consequences.
Right, it comes with homeowners building themselves
in floodplains close to the coast where yes,
sea level rise, storm surges, hurricanes will,
you know, at some point necessitate this sort
of bailout and it's the government that comes
in and does so.
That can't continue forever.
Many more correlated events, climatic events
will certainly necessitate a rethinking of
how do we bail out homeowners?
How do we ensure that this sort of moral hazard
doesn't continue to happen forever.
Right, so that starts with ideas like, we
can't always rebuild every home in its current
place.
Now that's an impossible political decision
just to be clear, very, very difficult for
the mayor to say, "Sorry, you can't move back
there."
There are always trade offs.
Ever since philosopher Mick Jagger told us,
"You can't always get what you want."
Right, of course, we know that.
And so there are trade offs in the real sense.
If you spend a trillion dollars on one thing,
it's not available for something else.
Now, that's what makes this search for measures
that in fact, do more than one thing at a
time.
So important.
JACOB: Yes.
There will be choices and they will become
ever more difficult and urgent.
Now here's one problem.
Those with the resources for them, it's not
a difficulty to adapt.
It's those folks without resources, within
our own cities, but also globally.
And just think of these little atoll islands
in the Pacific and the Indian oceans, like
the Maldive islands and so on.
They were the ones that hardly contributed
to global warming.
It's us, and yet they pay already the price.
They are already having to leave their island
atolls.
It is an equity issue because the people with
the least resources have the least power.
And yet often there are for historical reasons
living in the most endangered, coastal areas
because in their right mind, nobody would
build there in the first place.
And then where would we put those people?
We put them where nobody else wants to live
and the only places that are left over are
those that are most endangered by flooding.
SIERRA: And people with less resources, you
can't just afford to pick up and leave.
JACOB: Of course not.
And that's why we have to have a government
plan that assists those who need it most in
the best possible way, which means we have
to first create public housing in high-lying
areas.
So when the day comes that they really have
to leave, the housing is already there that
they can move into.
WAGNER: Frankly, one of the most important
things to know about adaptation is the rich
will adapt.
Of course, so the rich jet off with their
private plane to higher ground.
The poor will suffer.
OVINK: Climate change is not an abstract future,
it is here and now.
And the impacts are everywhere every day.
Google a flood, a drought, a storm, a disaster,
and you find more than one every day somewhere
around the world.
Who suffers?
The most vulnerable in every country around
a region.
And in the context of a health crisis like
a pandemic, in the context of terrorism, in
the context of economic decline and biodiversity
loss, those climate impacts are massive.
They are just, sometimes the last event pushes
a community over the brink of collapse.
Coming out of the climate conference, the
COP 26 in Glasgow, adaptation rose to the
top of the agenda.
Why?
Because the most vulnerable, the most marginalized
of the world are impacted now not, tomorrow.
We have to take action now to protect the
most vulnerable first and then build on that
level of protection to protect the rest of
the world.
SIERRA: Well, I mean, with that, I guess my
question is, is there a centralized authority
in the US for coordinating and resourcing
such a massive effort?
HILL: We do not have a central location for
all of these issues.
I haven't heard much talk about creating a
new national department.
I think a good place to start is simply creating
a national adaptation strategy, which is what
we do in other areas where you have a multitude
of agencies with responsibilities to responding
to the particular problem or crisis.
On top of governance and institutional leadership.
There needs to be buy-in at the community
level.
And rallying this type of buy-in is a massive
challenge in and of itself.
Trust me, I’ve seen it firsthand.
SIERRA: How do you manage getting people on
board?
Because I specifically think about my parents
in Manhattan Beach, which is an extreme flood
zone.
They were flooded by Sandy and the way that
my mother talks about their community group
meetings, and you know, they can't even agree
on these measures within their own community.
You know, how do you get people on board with
these solutions?
OVINK: I remember when we started Rebuild
By Design and we started to reach out to the
communities in the aftermath of Hurricane
Sandy, a lot of community said, "We don't
really see the benefit of working with you,
and why?
I mean, who are you?
The government, we don't have that good experience."
And that was even a nice way of what was said,
of course not always in the most friendly
way.
But we came back and said, "Okay, you know,
we need to work with you.
It's not about us telling you what to do,
but it's about us together figuring out what
is actually your needs.
It's possible, but it's not easy, but that
it is not easy should not prevent us from
trying.
SIERRA: Nobody wants to have to go through
radical changes in their community.
Nobody wants massive expenditures.
And most of all... nobody wants to leave the
home or city they love behind.
But some of these things will be necessary
because of the climate effects that are already
baked into the equation.
The time to start preparing is now.
SIERRA: Still, the most extreme adaptation
measures don't have to happen.
We can avoid them if we get way more serious
about mitigation.
SIERRA: Remember, the two things are linked.
The more we mitigate the less we will have
to adapt.
And that’s why keeping warming at or below
1.5 degrees celsius is critical.
OVINK: Without mitigation, there is no future.
The world is on the brink of collapse with
four or five, six, seven, eight, nine degrees
climate change.
So without mitigation, it is like we die tomorrow.
But without adaptation, we die today.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we’d love it if you
could leave us a review.
Ideally a good one, the more stars the better.
It really does help us get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Asher
Ross, Jeremy Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Rafaela Siewert is our associate podcast producer.
Our intern is Roshni Rangwani.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Claire Felter.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!